daredevil Nik Wallenda returned to the
highwire one day after escaping an
accident that hospitalized five fellow
acrobats walinda performed last night at
circus Sarasota after rehearsal ended in
a terrifying fall the five other
performers including his aunt and sister
fell about 30 feet to the ground while
attempting a record-breaking
eight person pyramid Omar Villafranca is
in Sarasota where the circus as its home
Omar good morning good morning circus
Sarasota will open tonight to the public
as planned but last night Nik Wallenda
and his performers were under this big
top again for an emotional show in front
of friends and family and it included a
death-defying stunt legendary circus
performer Nik Wallenda took to the air
again Thursday night surrounded and
supported by his circus family
Melinda was performing with a heavy
heart
one day after five circus performers
including his aunt and sister were
injured in an accident on Wednesday
Melinda and seven other performers were
practicing a high-wire pyramid trick
similar to this one shown here when
something went dangerously wrong but
five others fell nearly 30 feet to the
ground they were rushed to the hospital
two performers have been released three
remain hospitalized but all are expected
to fully recover Melinda was joined
Thursday night by one of the performers
who was standing on his shoulders when
the accident happened
another daredevil involved was also
honored the tight-knit circus community
has been struggling to stay in business
Ringling Brothers Circus closed last
month after 146 years in a recent local
newspaper profile circus Sarasota said
its audience has grown over time
claiming last year their shows sold out
that the circus does not tour keeping
costs low the circus
and I know that you guys all have my
backs I can't thank you guys enough for
reaching out I love you guys exactly
what caused the fall is still a mystery
circus officials say there was nothing
wrong with the equipment but Nik
Wallenda thinks that one of the
performers may have blacked out for a
second and that is all it takes
Gail I'll say that's scary stuff Thank
You Omar in that situation nobody can
have a bad day yeah everybody has to do
it perfectly